okay so today I want to have a
conversation with you about the facts of
the 2020 Democratic primary the fact is
that right now today March 4th Bernie
Sanders is the Democratic frontrunner
for the 2020 Democratic presidential
nomination period okay now let me be
clear about what this story is not this
is not a story of me endorsing Bernie
Sanders I've not decided yet who I'm
supporting in the 2020 Democratic
primary I've said Bernie is among my top
contenders but this is not an
endorsement of Bernie Sanders this is
not a story about who should you support
or who is ultimately going to be the
nominee this is merely a story about the
fact that if we want to assess who the
front-runner is as of today it is Bernie
Sanders and I am going to tell you
exactly why in a moment now it's also
important for me to remind you things
can and often do change in the point
during the period between 16 months
prior to the election and the time that
the Democratic National Convention takes
place we're about 16 months from the DNC
in the summer of 2020 that's when the
Democratic candidate will officially be
named very frequently the front-runner
in March of the year before is not the
eventual nominee things are very
different now of course than they have
been in the past but that's just sort of
a word of reality that right now it's
very often difficult to know who is
ultimately going to be the nominee
I believe that Bernie Sanders is now the
frontrunner along three different lines
number one name recognition number two
polling and number three fundraising
when you look at those three categories
in concert Bernie Sanders is the
undeniable frontrunner so let me lay it
out for you first and then we'll kind of
talk about the implications will start
with polling when it comes to polling
polling isn't everything
polling isn't always exactly accurate
but taken in the aggregate when we look
at polling before Bernie declared that
he was running and after Bernie declared
that he was running Bernie Sanders is
the front-runner
out of the candidates who are officially
part of the race now why am i mentioning
that last part because of Joe Biden okay
Joe Biden is actually winning most polls
he's just not a candidate right now if
he becomes one then we will have to
revisit this but if you look at a list
of recent polling that has been done the
morning consult poll has Bernie ahead
with 27% remember there's like 10 plus
candidates the d cy fo r poll has Bernie
at 14% that's actually in the lead out
of the candidates that have declared the
Harvard Harris Poll has Bernie at 22%
the Harris X poll has Bernie at 12%
ahead of Kamala Harris by only one
percentage point that's from before
Bernie even announced his candidacy the
morning consult poll from February 17th
also from before Bernie even announced
had him ahead at 21% and Emerson College
from before Bernie announced also had
Bernie with a plurality of support at
17% out of the candidates who are
running it's important to know that in
all but one of these polls Joe Biden is
ahead of Bernie Sanders and in some
cases significantly so even though he
hasn't declared his candidacy we're
going to get back to that at the end of
this story
so that's polling polling isn't
everything okay what about crowd sizes
crowd sizes also aren't everything but
being able to be a primary candidate
this early on and garner significant
crowds is an important thing Bernie
Sanders held his first rally over the
weekend in Brooklyn massive crowd
outdoors in the cold on a day that it
had been snowing off and on an estimated
crowd size of 13,000 so that is also a
point that we should be considering but
we know crowds can be deceptive and
don't actually tell you that much what
does tell you a lot and our system is
money
fundraising Bernie Sanders raised more
than three million dollars in the first
eight hours of his campaign that more
than doubled Kamala Harris
entire first day he's expecting to hit 1
million website signups of people who
want to be either participating in the
campaign or kept up-to-date on news
about the campaign and his fundraising
fundraising is absolutely off the charts
that's a really really important factor
and then lastly is name recognition and
this is a really really interesting one
because if you think back to 2016 Bernie
Sanders had relatively low name
recognition yes he was known to people
who had political shows like the David
Pakman show he was known to people in
the Northeast disproportionately but he
did not have significant name
recognition and in part that's probably
why he was really working uphill for a
huge portion of the campaign just to get
anybody on corporate media to even pay
attention to him contrast' that too now
the beginning of the 2020 election
process of the people already running
today is there anyone we can say Pat has
the name recognition of Bernie on the
Democratic side other than maybe
Elizabeth Warren I mean I can't think of
anybody else it's not Booker it's not
camel Harris I was gonna say that it's
not camel Harris I don't think it's
Booker it certainly is an Amy Klobuchar
I think Bernie Sanders is number one by
a longshot
I believe at this point Bernie Sanders
also has the name recognition advantage
in this primary so I don't think that
there is any substantive case to be made
that there is a different frontrunner at
this point in time on March 4th of 2019
than Bernie Sanders now that's the
situation today how can things change
what are we paying attention to to see
where this is going to go going forward
as I mentioned before number one usually
the front-runner in March of the year
before the election doesn't end up being
the nominee that's a historical argument
historical arguments against Donald
Trump were made and they failed so
that's merely a historical argument that
says Bernie is not going to be the
ultimate nominee but everything is
different in the era of Trump number 2
Joe Biden if Joe Biden enters this race
I believe he's instantly the
runner based on current polling I would
actually expect more support for Joe
Biden if he ends up declaring because as
we saw with Bernie when Bernie formally
announced his candidacy his support went
up in polls and Joe Biden is doing
really really well in the national polls
number three what is the role of the DNC
going to be here we know that there are
different degrees that people claim the
DNC affected the 2016 primary there are
those who say they may have preferred
Hillary but ultimately she got millions
more votes than Bernie anyway and we
can't say that it was merely because of
the DNC that Bernie lost there are
others who say Bernie would have been
the nominee were it not for the DNC
whatever your position is on that issue
there's an open question as to in what
ways will the DNC get involved in the
2020 Democratic primary and number four
and maybe most importantly remember that
there are foreign and domestic efforts
to create infighting among Democrats and
among supporters of the different
Democratic candidates we can't allow
that to succeed the media even despite
its best efforts if we're charitable
covers Bernie in a way that they play
into the idea that he's bad for
Democrats that he's bad for the left we
don't know what Bernie versus Trump
would mean we don't know who would have
won in 2016 had it been Bernie versus
Trump and I can assure you that people
in corporate media definitely don't know
what the meaning of Bernie versus Trump
would be so that's kind of where I am on
this right now Pat one side note is as
far as Elizabeth Warren goes and as I
mentioned she's one of my top contenders
for who I would support her campaign is
in trouble and I've been reading some op
eds that suggest her campaign may be far
more short-lived than initially imagined
as a combination of how she handled the
Native American DNA situation which was
a fiasco and more generally her poor
interviewing skills I don't know where
you are on this Pat but I'm reading more
and more stuff
elizabeth warren simply is not going to
go the distance
yeah Lizabeth Warren is going to be
fighting for the same group of people
that Bernie Sanders appeals to and I
think Bernie Sanders comes across as a
lot more likable a lot more authentic
he's been doing this for longer serving
in Congress for quite some time and I
think he would have the advantage there
over Elizabeth Warren who's more prone
to gaffes probably not as likable and is
not as progressive at the end of the day
so get me your thoughts about the
Elizabeth Warren thing but most
importantly here's what I want to hear
from the audience about if you can make
a fact-based an empirical case for
Bernie Sanders not being the
front-runner today I want to hear from
you right so that would be a case to
understand it's this can't be Bernie's
not even a Democrat and I don't like him
okay that that's not what I'm looking to
hear from I know we'll see lots of those
comments on YouTube on this video what I
want to hear from you is David here's
where your facts are wrong about polling
fundraising and name recognition that's
one possibility or David your facts are
right about polling fundraising and name
recognition but here is what you didn't
mention that explains why Bernie Sanders
is not actually the front-runner right
now that's the that's what I want to
hear from people and if we get some good
explanation some good defenses of
someone else being the front-runner then
I'll bring them to you later in the week
and we can continue the conversation
about it make sure that you follow the
david pakman show on Instagram where we
will be letting you vote on upcoming
show segments the show is on instagram
at david pakman show and while you're
there follow me as well at David Pakman
scandal breaking out over the weekend on
my Instagram I posted a picture of
myself eating a burger and as I'm known
to do I eat burgers what is bi by the
traditional consumers of burgers known
as upside down and a complete crazy
battle has broken out on my Instagram
page over the burger fiasco am i eating
it upside down am I not is it good to
eat burgers upside down anyway you can
debate it if you follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman the more serious topic
here is Bernie Sanders being the
front-runner for 2020 and I look forward
to hearing from you about that